- [Narrator] There's a small
neighborhood in Montréal
known as Mile End, which has become
an unlikely hub for gaming companies.
- It is now a neighborhood that has
a high concentration of people who
work in game development.
The Mile End is the home of
some of the most creative
and most recognized
game ideas in the history
of modern video games.
- [Narrator] One of
these is Minority Media,
a company that's the catalyst for
a burgeoning video game
genre called empathy gaming
where players are forced to confront
real human issues like bullying,
alcoholism, or depression.
Gamers place themselves in
the shoes of the character
to feel and try and understand
what they are going through.
- What we're trying to do here is
we're trying to put people
in a different mindset.
We're trying to put people
into a different perspective.
As Canadians, we're used to being able to
put ourselves in other peoples' shoes.
We're used to looking at things
from a different perspective.
Gaming can be for anybody, for everybody.
We're taking advantage of the
educational possibilities.
We've developed a language game
for a school board up in northern Québec.
They've approached us to do a game
for the grade one students.
We've worked with the curriculum
that they've established.
We've developed the story behind that
and made that into a game.
- Empathy games themselves have
become a less exclusive genre
and have integrated
themselves into bigger games.
And so, empathy games have influenced
the way bigger games are made now.
- There is room to go a lot deeper
into what gaming can actually be.
There's a universe of possibilities.
And so, I think, uh, we've only
just begun scratching the surface.